happy monday my monday friends i hope
you had a great weekend i did
so big news over at national public
radio which may be the first time
anyone's ever said that
they announced they're launching a
disinformation reporting team featuring
journalists whose ex expertise
apparently is fake news
well that must have been hard to find
every journalist these days is an expert
on fake news it's like saying a french
bulldog is an expert on farting
that's all they do
something about their flat faces i don't
know but it's good to see npr finally
realizing the necessity of policing fake
news sort of like a drug addict checking
himself into rehab you know admitting
you have a problem npr is the first step
so good for you
but will their first investigation be of
themselves this tweet from npr itself
right before the 2020 election
here npr asks why you haven't seen
stories from them about the new york
post story on hunter biden which the
paper broke a month or so before the
2020 election
as you know the story was flushed down a
toilet like an ounce of crack when
cops kick in hunter's front door
debating whether to reread that
they got it it's monday
monday i have a lot on my mind
yeah so they bury the story only to
resurface it later when hunter's dad was
safely transported to the oval office
like a mannequin to a storefront window
and unlike joe trying to complete a
handshake
the whole thing the whole thing worked
perfectly
this is npr's explanation for not
covering the story quote we don't want
to waste our time on stories that aren't
really stories and we don't want to
waste listeners in readers times on
stories that are just pure distractions
well if that were the case then what
would be left a segment on the
challenges of trans folk singers in the
himalayas
which is just more evidence of the white
patriarchy at work
it's funny in an urgent moment when news
is vital no one's ever yelled quick put
on npr
[Laughter]
unless it's to put a patient to sleep
for emergency surgery
but how thoughtful of them yeah
apparently npr was doing people a favor
by filtering out stories that might
disturb them but they really weren't
filtering at all they were blocking
cherry picking censoring then acting as
if it was a favor to you pulling that
tote bag over your head and saying it's
for your own good sister
here you got the biggest most
consequential story of the election
season and they buried it like a mouthy
hitchhiker in the desert
wouldn't shut up
they called something fake news when
it's real and assumed no one would call
them on it which for the most part they
were right but they knew they had to do
their part to protect old joe as his
campaign wobbled into the white house
like a rascal scooter with two bad
wheels
that's not a mistake or disinformation
or joe reading the name branded warranty
info office teleprompter
it's called lying and npr did it to
influence an election
i wonder what happened though behind
closed doors
okay boss i've got some story pitches
for you let me know what you think
hunter biden weighing crack with a
hooker yeah
no how about
hunter biden with two hookers and a dog
doesn't feel like a story to me all
right i see where you're going with this
how about hunter biden in a tank smoking
crack while touching himself jerry let's
just pick stories how we always do with
the cheese singles
[Laughter]
non-binary indigenous patio furniture
there's a story
i'll go write it up thank you
that's how it's done
all right
so now they start at disinformation
bureau but of course the only dis info
they're gonna focus on is the stuff that
flows only in one direction and that
would be from right to left because if
they didn't wouldn't they first address
the hidden hunter story right out of the
gate well unless you enjoy turning blue
when rendering yourself unconscious
don't hold your minty fresh breath
we actually contacted npr to find out if
they would and we got nothing but an
automated email and response i guess mpr
stands for no professional response
[Laughter]
got a clever ass audience tonight yes
but i get why
npr's attempt at fact-checking is no
different than all the other jokers who
claim to fact check as they let more
whoppers slide through like brian
stelter's digestive tract
meanwhile they'll chase down memes by
private citizens or dox them for making
jokes or worse telling the truth
yep after an exhaustive investigation we
found that there really was no cat
holding on to a tree branch saying hang
in there
we also found no evidence that there is
a frog named pepe
meanwhile i've been doing my own
experiment with fact checkers in the
last week alone i've deliberately
mentioned that dr jill is a medical
doctor
and not a single correction from the
fact checkers
i'm serious
means i'm going to go ahead with having
her remove my gallbladder
it was nice knowing you folks
but i keep waiting for the washington
post or politifact or anyone to call me
on it but they don't and why because
even though i made it up it's a lie that
fits their narrative so who cares but
maybe it's not their fault maybe they're
confused because dr jill's always seen
with that shuffling elderly man
she's a month away from going to joe's
press events wearing scrubs and carrying
a bedpan
that's date night
[Laughter]
thank you
but that's the way it goes
the real fake news is actually npr's
approach to fake news it's a false front
to appear like they're tackling
something when in fact they're just
creating another wall of interference
against real news hitting their viewers
it's another user interface to protect
their listeners from the truth much in
the way fox security protects me from
overzealous fans you know it's the
teenage girls who are really aggressive
but i keep it classy
[Laughter]
but just like the flimsy tote bags that
npr gives away nobody's buying it no
matter how earnest and gentle your
voices are when reporting it we hear the
bs loud and clear
your response to fake news is just more
fake news fact check that out
[Applause]
yes
every time he speaks i feel like i'm
about to get grounded co-host of the
five judge
[Applause]
and when he performs on cruise ships
they aim for icebergs after writer's
comedian jamie lissa
[Applause]
oh and speak of the devil
and she'll appear
foxy's contributor cat tim
[Applause]
and when he's under the weather he just
stands up
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
[Applause]
judge how you doing happy monday
how's life treating you everything good
i don't like mondays yeah you don't no
you don't like it either you know what i
was thinking when you were going through
that open which i thought was brilliant
oh thank you has there always been fake
news or is this just getting worse that
was my question and that was my question
is it it was not yes here let me picked
it up for me do you think do you think
fake news is a new phenomenon with
social media or has it always been
around but we've never really looked oh
so what do you think i think i think
that we i bet you that walter cronkite
and harry reisner and all those folks
probably trafficked in their own media
assumptions too
i don't know i don't want to believe
that i know you know i mean we were
taught to believe that they were truly
objective yeah but we didn't know what
objectivity was until fox came in and
she showed how left-wing everybody yeah
and ripped down the curtain yeah i hate
it when people do that to me
i get it that's what i mean
especially the shower curtain am i right
judge
can't control herself
oh i don't know
don't even don't even try to
should follow my train of thought today
you know jamie you just got in on a
red-eye flight didn't you i did and that
intro just freaked me out where you said
they would aim for icebergs yes because
uh i used to really do comedy on alaskan
cruise ships sometimes yeah and the best
part of those is like the people are so
old like they're so old that you can be
as offensive as you want as a comedian
and they can't walk out even if they
want to
[Applause]
can they hear you yeah
[Music]
that's half the battle if they can't
so what do you make of this all this
fake news this disinformation do you get
the feeling they're only gonna look at
one side of the coin i do get that
feeling and i also thought it was
strange that they're like oh we're gonna
form this committee that's gonna figure
out which news stories are real and
which ones aren't and i was like you
probably should have been doing that
exactly as a news program she's doing it
the whole time it's almost like remember
when there was covid and then certain
like uh businesses were like hey because
of covey like you go to a hotel they go
wait because it coveted we're gonna
we're gonna wash the sheets
and you're like what you guys weren't
washing the sheets yeah yeah we're gonna
start wiping down the things we should
yeah
we're gonna get like a box of cheerios
yes i read this terrible article i
shouldn't even bring it up because i
can't stop thinking about it and it said
the dirtiest part of a hotel it says the
doorknob actually did you know that i
said the doorknob has fecal matter on it
yes yes
the doorknob at the hotel the handle of
the door and i was just thinking like
fecal matter how many things do you have
to be carrying
that in order to open the door you use
your butt
oh that was good that was a good
question tyrus
he raises a very high i'd say maybe six
things
[Laughter]
that was correct i can hold that's
correct i can hold 47 grocery bags in
one hand so yeah
i would love to go shopping t i'd like
to take you to costco just because i'd
put you in the cart yes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that'd be so much fun
you know greg uh the question you didn't
ask judge but judge brought up um
it didn't used to be there because news
wasn't about ratings it was about news
and we had
the crazy stuff when you were in line
there was like bat-faced boy breeds with
elephant and the inquirer joshua gabor
mary's alien we had all the crazy
stories in those little papers no one
ever talks about how they were run out
of business by like cnns and stuff
because they stole all the fun stories
and the fake stories and stuff to get
ratings and make money and have careers
and journalists were pushed out for
people identifying as journalists but
really were just opinionated and
one-sided so that's that's i think when
walter was in walter wasn't getting
sponsors and walter wasn't getting paid
to tell one side or the other and he
wasn't pushing an election and stuff so
it did change once it went to ratings
the game was over and news is profitable
i was the original source code for
batboy did you know that
yes actually i did yeah it's you have
the tattoo of it on the small of the top
of your head that is true that's true
only you could see it there you go
wow that was a that was a necessary cat
you think um
so hard people are so mean to you it is
it's true it's true you know um i
believe that also i mean we have to have
some responsibility here and the fact
that once news goes 24 7 you got to fill
all these buckets and a lot of these
buckets are going to be filled with you
know gruel
yeah yeah
that's just my comment yeah except they
won't fill them with gruel they fill it
with like stuff that has been
sensationalized that really is sometimes
boring or not that big of a deal yes uh
i think that
the most important thing to consider is
probably just the motive
in terms of when someone's telling you
something like do they have a motive to
tell me this what is it why and also
your own motive because a lot of times
when you want to believe something you
will yeah
that's a very good point you're talking
about confirmation bias i sure am yes
[Laughter]
bucket of gruel got failed i got a gruel
you
normally be a different bucket
what does that mean
oh
i get it yes i have shifted away from
certain topics to other topics look at a
regular old gruel yes he's trying to egg
me
everybody's mean to me i don't know what
did i do it's just a bucket of gruel
up next is dr jill joe's newest show
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else